Salut moussaillons, prêts à saborder tous
les navires marchands qui croiseront votre
route pour faire un peu d'honnête piraterie?
-Ohla, non.
Tu arrives trop tôt.
Beaucoup trop tôt.
-C'est toi qui lui a dit qu'elle pouvait apparaître
en premier?
-Cet épisode concerne la piraterie, je me
trompe? Je vous honore de ma présence dans
le but d'informer votre public sur mon noble
métier.
-Oui, euh...
En fait tu as quelques siècles d'avance,
là.
On a décidé de parler de l'histoire de la
piraterie en général, et bien que tu sois
très représentative de la piraterie au XVII,
XVIIIe siècle...
Je pense pas que tu puisse nous dire grand
chose sur l'Antiquité par exemple.
-Ah.
Chou blanc, donc.
-On te rappellera quand ça sera ton tour.
-C'est ça, à tout à l'heure!
Et c'est parti pour un historique de la piraterie
à travers les époques.
Quand on parle de piraterie on pense à Tortuga,
aux tricornes et aux perroquets sur l'épaule,
mais j'avais envie dans cet épisode de montrer
une vision un peu plus globale de la piraterie,
de ses enjeux et de ses différentes formes.
Le Bureau Maritime International définit
la piraterie comme «l'acte de monter à bord
d'un navire avec l'intention de commettre
un vol ou tout autre crime et avec l'intention
ou la capacité d'utiliser la force»
-Non!
Nous reviendrons dans notre dernière partie
sur d'autres définitions contemporaines de
la piraterie et sur les problèmes juridiques
qu'elles peuvent poser.
En tout cas dès l'Antiquité on qualifie
de pirates des bandits maritimes qui s'attaquent
à d'autres navires ou aux villes portuaires.
La piraterie apparaît ainsi dès l'apparition
des nations maritimes.
Les auteurs de l'Antiquité parlent fréquemment
dans leurs ouvrages de violences, de pillages,
d'enlèvements...
Comme dans l'Odyssée d'Homère, où Ulysse
va s'attaquer au peuple des Kikones
-Kikou!
Et pratique donc un acte de piraterie.
Dans la mythologie grecque, il existe également
un épisode durant lequel le dieu Dionysos,
alcoolique notoire, est capturé par des pirates.
Dans l'espace méditerranéen, on peut citer
dans un premier temps les phéniciens, qui
vivent par ici (carte) et dominent le trafic
méditerranéen à partir de 1200 avant J.C.
Ils pratiquent le commerce maritime mais également
la piraterie, les deux étant encore étroitement
liés.
Avec l'expansion des cités grecques, qui
dépendent elles aussi grandement du commerce
maritime, la piraterie en Méditerranée pose
problème et encourage les villes à se fortifier.
Les pirates de cette époque utilisent des
bateaux longs et de plus petite taille que
les navires marchands, ce qui les rend plus
rapides et maniables que ceux qu'ils souhaitent
attaquer.
Ils sont essentiellement d'origine grecque,
crétoise ou d'Asie Mineure, et la piraterie
se concentre dans la partie orientale de la
Méditerranée dont les côtes très découpées
(carte) et la présence de nombreuses îles
est propice à la piraterie.
Les bases de pirates sont ainsi des petite
crique dominées par une hauteur, ce qui ne
manque pas dans ces régions, permettant de
guetter les navires et d’abriter le butin.
A Rome, les pirates sont les principaux fournisseurs
d'esclaves et sont donc dans un premier temps
tolérés.
Ils commencent quand même à poser problème
au premier siècle avant J.C.
Déjà, ils s'attaquent à des villes de l'Empire,
et ça plaît moyennement à Rome.
-On veut bien des esclaves, mais faudrait
pas qu'en plus ils viennent de chez nous!
-Ils kidnappent aussi des sénateurs et personnalités
importantes contre une demande de rançon,
comme César, capturé en 75 avant J.C., et
qui une fois libéré retourne voire ses pirates
pour leur péter la gueule.
Et enfin, de par leurs activités, ils commencent
à gêner le ravitaillement à Rome.
Et ça, ça n'est pas acceptable.
Cicéron définit les pirates comme les «ennemis
de tous», comme ça c'est pas compliqué.
-Attention: si tu prépares le Capes d'Histoire-géographie,
le passage qui va suivre peut t'être utile.
-En 67 avant J.C., face à cette menace grandissante,
la loi Gabinia confie à Pompée des pouvoirs
étendus afin qu'il aille régler une fois
pour toutes le problème de la piraterie.
Il dispose d'un imperium, c'est à dire d'une
puissance militaire, qui s'étend sur toute
la Méditerranée jusqu'aux colonnes d'Hercule,
c'est-à-dire le détroit de Gibraltar, et
jusqu'à 75km à l'intérieur des terres.
C'est un grand pouvoir pour l'époque.
-Et il implique une grande responsabilité.
-Il parvient donc à mettre pratiquement fin
à la piraterie en quelques mois, en délogeant
les pirates de leurs repaires en Méditerranée
orientale.
Cicéron, encore lui, vante son action en
déclarant:
«Au jour où vous l'avez chargé de la
guerre des pirates, on a vu, grâce à l'espoir
que donnait le nom d'un seul homme, le prix
des denrées, qui étaient extrêmement rares
et chères, baisser tout à coup comme après
une récolte extraordinaire et au sein d'une
longue paix.
»
Rome lutte également contre la piraterie
hors de la Méditerranée, à mesure que son
empire s'étend, contre les Pictes et les
Scandinaves en mer du Nord et en Baltique.
Ils construisent pour cela des tours de guet,
à la demande de Léodagan bien sûr.
-Ce dernier passage, par contre, n'est pas
à citer dans tes oraux de Capes.
-Avec le déclin progressif de l'empire romain,
la piraterie reprend des forces au cours du
premier millénaire aussi bien dans la Méditerranée
qu'en mer du Nord.
On a déjà cité les vikings sur lesquels
je ne reviendrai donc pas, et nous allons
nous intéresser à la montée de la piraterie
durant le Moyen-Âge.
A partir du XIIe siècle, la piraterie change
d'acteurs mais pas d'espaces: on la retrouve
dans la Manche, la mer du Nord et la Méditerranée.
Au Nord, la Manche est un passage particulièrement
difficile: comme on l'a vu dans l'Antiquité,
la piraterie se pratique dans les espaces
étroits, difficiles d'accès, tels que les
détroits ou les archipels.
On trouve peu de piraterie en haute mer, ne
serait-ce que parce que la probabilité d'y
croiser un navire est plutôt faible.
Le commerce dans la Manche est donc très
perturbé par la piraterie.
En plus les États concernés, la France et
l'Angleterre, ne possède pas de marine à
proprement parler pour réguler ce banditisme.
On peut citer au XIIIe siècle le cas d'Eustache
le Moine, qui pratique la piraterie de 1205
environ à 1217.
Parce qu'à cette date là, il meurt..
On peut même le considérer comme une sorte
de corsaire, puisqu'il est parfois au service
de Philippe Auguste, pour la France, et parfois
au service de Jean sans Peur, pour l'Angleterre.
-Et pour Saint-George!
-D'ailleurs, un corsaire est quelqu'un qui
pratique la piraterie au nom d'une nation,
il possède un petit papier qui dit «j'autorise
ce bon monsieur à vous pirater». Un corsaire
au service de l'Angleterre peut donc allégrement
piller les navires ennemis sans craindre d'être
inquiété par la Royal Family.
-Par contre, on est toujours le pirate de
quelqu'un dans cette histoire.
Si tu es un brave corsaire pour les anglais,
tu n'es qu'un sale pirate pour les français.
Et vice et versa.
La distinction entre pirates et corsaires
prend surtout de l'importance à l'époque
moderne, que nous aborderons ensuite.
Pour l'instant, les deux termes sont employés
comme synonymes.
Intéressons-nous à nouveau à la Méditerranée
maintenant, où la piraterie bat son plein!
Elle reprend progressivement avec l'expansion
musulmane, et prend une telle importance qu'elle
freine le commerce méditerranéen durant
une grande partie du deuxième millénaire.
Elle est principalement le fait des dynasties
berbères et arabes du Maghreb, on désigne
donc par le terme de «barbaresque» les
pirates méditerranéens basés au Maghreb
entre le XVIe et le XIXe siècle!
-Barbare, berbère.
Waouh!
-C'est principalement depuis la ville d'Alger,
qui est sous domination ottomane, que partent
les pirates malgré les tentatives inefficaces
de répression de la part des royaumes européens.
Charles Quint, par exemple, s'attaque à Alger
en 1541 mais subit une défaite cuisante.
Les pirates portent le nom de raïs, ils sont
corsaires au service de la ville d'Alger et
participent surtout au commerce d'esclaves
grâce à leurs prisonniers.
C'est l'importance de cette piraterie, jusqu'au
XIXe siècle, qui explique en partie l'intervention
militaire de la France en Algérie à partir
des années 1830, qui met fin à la régence
ottomane sur ces territoires et entraîne
la colonisation du Maghreb.
Mais le temps s'écoule, comme dirait Davy
Jones, et il ne sera pas dit que je ferai
une vidéo de plus de 15mn aujourd'hui!
Je vous donne donc rendez-vous la prochaine
fois pour la suite de cette formidable aventure
à travers les époques à la rencontre des
pirates.
-En parlant de rencontre...
J'suis venue pour rien alors, c'est ça?
-On t'avais dit que t'étais en avance.
-Et on va même pas tourner la suite aujourd'hui,
alors tu peux ramer jusque chez toi, on te
rappellera!
-MERCI.
Mais vous vous rappellerez du jour où vous
avez failli...
-A la prochaine pour un épisode sur la piraterie
du XVIIe siècle à nos jours, bonjour chez
vous et merci de votre attention!